you wake up at something like 3 A.M or 5
a.m and the first two to three days the
only instruction they give you is hey uh
feel how the breath feels on your lips
when you're breathing in and out okay
see you in three days and you sit there
it's really extreme what this is my
management style too
[Music]
all right we're live here we have a
guest Jack Smith one of my best friends
in my wedding
an amazing person I don't even know how
to describe you jack what you I guess
like the top line is you started a
company that you sold for like 800
million dollars when you were 29. that's
like the that's like the the headline
impressive stuff but we have you here
because you have done you're just like
one of the more interesting people I
know okay well thanks for having me I
also for kind of an interesting contrast
coming after Rob
um because like he was describing
himself as like the Pinnacle of human
optimization right like he plans how
long it takes him to go to the toilet
each day and I was thinking I'm maybe an
instant contrast so I'm like human
procrastination like the exact opposite
of that so yeah but you do optimize
stuff like Sean I don't know if you know
this but it's like Jack one time he went
to his birthday party and his wife made
him a cake and it was in the shape of an
Amazon box because he had this like it
was like a walk-in closet but it was
basically a room in his home and it was
full of Amazon boxes and you're like
Jack what is that any he has this list
this Excel spreadsheet that he keeps and
anything that he buys ranging from a
book bag to baby uh apparel or baby
accessories or one time he was obsessed
with chocolate he would literally buy 50
versions and test all of them and then
rank them on this like attribute system
and then have a and so he has these huge
lists of everything that he's tested and
he's done this so much that we're
haven't you been banned from Amazon like
multiple times yeah and then also
bonobos had this policy for I don't know
if they still have I think for many
years I had a policy where you could
return any item even if it was used up
to 365 days after and so I had a
spreadsheet tracking when I bought
everything basically I got a new
wardrobe every year because I just sent
all my clothes back on the 340 days and
then just got it all as like uh credit
and bought an entire new wardrobe every
year
um so yeah I got banned from Amazon a
few times
you would rather have more in common
than you than you think he's planted his
poops and you're planning your returns
in a giant spreadsheet which by the way
we should like give a background so
basically your company was called fungal
you how were you 22. I'm 21 20
um
so basically like the story that you
always tell is you had like you got into
an accelerator an incubator I think you
had one idea but it wasn't working out
and then you just like mocked up like a
PowerPoint you went and it was like on a
mobile ad Network so basically you would
see an ad in between levels of games you
brought it to developers and they're
like oh yeah this is way better if you
could actually build this we're in and
you did that a bunch of times where you
got maybe one or I think a million
dollars of the commitments of like yeah
I guess if you build this we would spend
like this much money and then you took
that and you actually hired a a
developer Bryant who's now the
co-founder of webflow and you built that
business and then it like spiraled into
this thing where I think you'd only
raised 10 or 15 million maybe 17 million
and within seven years I think wherever
it was when you sold you guys were doing
a million a day in Revenue
it could be in that region yeah maybe
yeah around hundreds of millions in
Revenue
it was absolutely crazy and then you
sold it for I forget what 800 yeah yeah
kind of in that region and I mean what's
interesting as well is obviously Sean
talks about having worked with one
um nothing app loving launched about six
to 12 months after us
so I think it's another example you
don't have to be the first to Market
like everyone's jumping on the AI Trend
right to be first to Market but actually
you don't have to be the first Market to
be the biggest app loving was one of the
slower movers and to get context they at
their Peak have been multiple times
bigger than fungal they went public and
probably at their peak in the region of
10 billion market cap now they're a bit
low up to the markets
they're nine billion now they were 20
billion at its peak uh something like 20
25 billion at this peak what do you
think they did why did they have kind of
a let's call it 10 to 20x bigger outcome
if they started a year later when you
look back what did you learn from that
and it was also interesting because uh
one of our investors besides fir Khan
being a beast
one of our investors came to us and said
like oh yeah we're backing we're looking
we're investing in this company they do
like um video advertisements inside of
uh mobile apps Etc called Apple Avenue
we're like uh you're describing our
company what are you talking about
you're investing in do that that's what
we did to do and actually uh so they're
caught uh they're called Web
um
uh win web investment Network they
invested in I think they're the only
investor invested in fungal and app
loving
um they're great guys but at the time we
were like
um so they have massive wins there uh
one bit we observed is actually app
loving bungle we thought that like at
the time before vungle mobile ads were
monetized food like banner ads like kind
of on the internet you know with
internet festivals she had these crappy
banner ads and we were like well they
obviously suck so we're gonna do video
ads which is 10x better but a difference
that app loving did is
they didn't only do video ads they did
everything they did they they were like
we don't care what you want to spend
money on we'll just take your money so
they're like one perform you can do
banner ads video ads everything and so I
think that um enabled them to capture a
bit more market share and perhaps
um the uh founding team being more
technical like I'm saying that I'm a
crappy engineer uh like I could not
build bungle from scratch and
Sean listening to your story on uh one
of the more recent episodes you
described furquon making that dashboard
for Adam that he could just look at the
apps and poach them right we did similar
bits
um but there's perhaps more technical
one of our hacks we did is we actually
had a team of people in about 10 people
in Pakistan
and Pakistan is so cheap so we had an
entire office and they had one job
two and this is why it was really easy
to recruit there
we said just play mobile games all day
we just got them all on iPhone and we
just like play games all day and
whenever you see an ad
write down what the ad was advertising
and what ad network was using it and so
they basically built us our lead gen
database by playing all the games so
maybe we did it manually they did it by
looking at this SDK source code and so
yeah that's amazing you're like last
night someone was asking me I was at
this dinner they're like have you ever
met anyone who
um created a business and sold it and
was wealthy enough and they just retired
and I was like not really basically
everyone I know who's started a company
and had some type of success usually
after some amount of time six months or
three years they usually get to
something sometimes it's more intense
sometimes less intense but they usually
do something you're actually the only
person I think I know who was incredibly
successful at a very young age so 30
years old or whenever you sold it and
you actually have not ever started
another business before you do a lot of
odd stuff like for example I'll be like
Jack what are you doing now you got any
projects you're like yeah
I have like a ton of pen pals in prison
and I like set up this thing where it's
this website where people inmates can
order any book they want to and I like
ask them to create like a book report on
it and I'm like that's so interesting do
you think a you'll ever get back into
business and is the reason do you just
spent all your days just like seeking
out all these interesting topics is that
what you're doing now
so I would not say that I'm retired at
the moment because when I think of being
retired I think about having no stress
and just like sitting around reading
books all day or something like that you
know actually I am working on a bunch of
stuff
um but they're not just it's not taking
approach of trying to build another
billion dollar company when I think back
a trait I notice in many entrepreneurs
and I observed in myself is that I think
um I was successful early on because I
had a chip on my shoulder I had
something to prove and I'm doing my
first um startup in London it was really
hard to do a startup and I also felt
like people kind of didn't respect me
um I had they like people
um just kind of thought I was a joke or
whatever and I kind of felt inside I
thought I was like I think that I can
build something successful I didn't want
I didn't aspire to be super rich or
anything I just wanted to build a big
company but I had that chip on my
shoulder something to prove now when
vungle Soul when I kind of reflected I
was like I don't think that I have that
chip on my shoulder anymore and I think
if you're gonna try and build a billion
dollar company you or or really Venture
that company or something you have to
make a lot of sacrifices right and
um have a drive about why you're doing
it and when I sat I'm like I don't need
more money now and I don't have this
thing to prove anymore
so when I sat with it I felt what is
going to motivate me more now is where
can I have an impact and kind of
impact the world not necessarily trying
to impact a million people in the world
but even if I just deeply impact a few
people in the world I think that will be
a driver to
a reason why to work on this because
making more money is not enough of a
driver for me and all of us free we're
in this chat group right about Founders
that have sold their first company and
it seems that
the majority of people have this crisis
I've sold my company but I don't know
what to do with myself and I'm good at
building companies I don't really need
more money but so I just do it because
that's what I'm good at and I can't
think of anything else to do and also I
don't want to just sit around so it
seems to challenge many others are
facing for me the conclusion I came to
was where can I add impact and that
looks like setting up some Charities and
a project that I'm working on at the
moment you guys have talked briefly
about it before is moved to Portugal to
set up a kind of
digital detox type place for people to
switch off from technology and be in
nature so these are the kind of things
I'm doing I mean that one it will
hopefully make money but money is not
the core metric if it's been a success
or not even if it doesn't even if it
breaks even or loses a bit of money if
just it can heal people people say like
yo that changed my life was super
healing to me and people talk about it
that is success for me with that project
dude you're the first person I've ever
met who does a lot of things that are
now more popular so I remember one time
Sean Jack and I were hanging out and we
are playing frisbee golf it was just us
it was like
10 a.m in the morning we're playing
frisbee golf in San Francisco and I was
like Jack you're being a little quiet
what's wrong and this was like after an
hour of playing he was like oh I am
I was doing Ayahuasca from for the last
three days and I was like what what's
Ayahuasca he's like well you go to this
house and you like drink this thing and
then you throw up and you're supposed to
like you know find yourself or whatever
and you have like a shaman guiding you
and I was like when did that end and he
was like oh I came straight from there I
was there like I was there like an hour
and a half ago and so you would do that
stuff like way before this type of
psychedelic stuff was popular another
thing that you would do Jack would come
and speak at hustlecon and he's like hey
I gotta go like literally the next day I
was like where are you going he goes oh
I'm going to Bali uh for three weeks for
a silent Retreat and he would I would
see him leave he would bring like
basically no clothes and a massive bag
like a whole carry-on or a whole check
bag of books from the library and I was
like what are you doing he's like I was
just overwhelmed with all the people I
got to go to Bali now for and he would
go to the silent Retreat for literally
three weeks and not say a word and now
I'm talking to like my quote normal more
normal friends my friends who are
doctors and lawyers whatever and now
they're doing it you do so many things
that are so odd and now every now
everyone's talking about psychedelics uh
like these silent Retreats are
significantly more popular you've been
doing that since 2012. I remember you
was telling me about all this stuff
because this is the crazy thing I've
ever heard of and you've been doing all
that now and it's way more popular
vipassana is a is a type of silent
meditation so if someone says they're
done a silent Retreat often they're
talking about this thing called
vipassana and yes I think it has got
more mainstream nowadays but it has
actually been pretty popular concept for
a long time but I've never done it and
that is actually really extreme approach
like um many people I speak to who have
done them so it's kind of like if you
can't swim and you jump off an olympic
diving board it's really extreme
approach to switching off and feeling
burned out some people I think they're
doing it because well I know people tell
me they did it because it sounded like a
challenge but it's not necessarily a
good thing so to give an example you go
for 10 days right my friend did it his
pillow was made it's run by monks it's a
non-profit they have about 300 locations
around the world run by monks and it
doesn't cost any money you maybe pay
small fee his pillow was made out of
concrete you're not allowed to make eye
contact with any other person there your
meals are like rice you wake up at
something like 3 A.M or 5am and the
first two to three days the only
instruction they give you is hey uh feel
how the breath feels on your lips when
you're breathing in and out okay see you
in three days and you sit there so it's
really extreme what this is my
management style too
but this is really popular but what I
did and I was inspired by Bill Gates he
had this thing called uh think week
where he just goes to a cabin in the
middle of nowhere and he just reads for
a week
and I was like oh that's awesome and I
found this place in Indonesia and it's
just totally different to uh the Persona
because they don't have any rules like
you can make like the only rollers don't
talk to each other but you can make eye
contact you can do whatever you want you
don't have to do any meditation at all
but and then so for me I just took loads
of books and I came out of that each
time getting all the benefits these
people doing big Persona Retreats talk
about like I feel super re-energized my
mood feels off the charts super happy
but I'm having an amazing time I'm
reading all these books I've wanted to
read all year and the food is amazing
it's grown on their own jungle slash
farm so I'm like this amazing experience
and I feel awesome and all these
benefits but since the other guys are
like oh
I spoke to one guy this morning he's
like
uh totally glad I did it would never
want to go through that again was one of
the hardest experiences of my life and
I'm like well you can actually get a
bunch of the same benefits but you don't
have to talk to yourself
but I've never found a place like this
place in Indonesia and so
for many years I kind of felt
that I just have to do this which is
expand their concept to other continents
around the world so I'm starting in
Portugal If that goes well hopefully
then expand to America
Etc
that's awesome you put a couple things
on the sheet that I want to do
um you said business opportunities so
you're not it sounds like you're not
doing
you've been able to resist the
temptation to start another business
even though you're good at business and
you see lots of opportunities so uh
share with us a couple of these like
random ideas that you have on this list
yeah because
um I know you guys like I think the
audience likes different business ideas
and things that are also actionable with
my first million wipes I was kind of
thinking to myself and one business I
don't know if you guys have come across
this but it was kind of interesting to
me
um it's a company not VC back or
anything but it's called Nomad
capitalist
and um is this guy and he's kind of made
a name for himself as
the leader for rich people that just
want to go around the world he organizes
a conference for like family offices and
he has a book and he has this brand
called Nomad capitalist and if you look
on Reddit loads of people talk about it
I actually did a pre-screen call with
them and I also read the reviews about
it Etc they're basically just
a reseller for tax lawyers because tax
lawyers just suck at marketing you know
and he's got a podcast he's got a book
he's just a really great at marketing
and he's got this like he's like oh the
best track strategy is to like have free
passports I help you get multiple
passports and set up a bank account in
another country Etc did a call with them
and they basically wanted 25 000
retainer
and then what they'll do is they'll just
make you a report and they're like all
right the 25 000 you can later put it
towards whatever things we propose for
you
but
um I was like okay but then as I did
more research I kind of just myself
found out like wait I can just cut out
you and just find an awesome tax
attorney myself and pay three thousand
dollars I don't need to give you 25 000
but he he had he's he's doing really
well and he also has this level like if
you pay him 75 000 you can like go and
hang out with him on an island in person
and he'll he'll cut he'll be your
concierge so some of these people I
think it's just like rich people having
too much money and they don't want to do
the research or reference checks to find
good tax people they're like oh well
this dude his website looks really great
he must be thought leader he's got this
book He's on all the podcasts I'll just
hire him because also I found tax
attorneys they don't give you a simple
answer to the freaking question you know
I'm just like I I want to do this
whatever and then they're like oh it's
really complicated and they use all this
jargon
they just suck at speaking plain English
he
um so he's built a really good business
and I was thinking I think a business
opportunity is building a reseller layer
on top of these industries that just
suck at marketing or communicating what
they do you know
um so he's doing it for tax
International tax for really rich people
and I was thinking there's probably
other Industries where just making
amazing brand website write a book go on
all the podcasts and make a brand about
yourself hit really great name right
like Nomad capitalist
um to do that for other Industries
um I thought was one idea so what do you
get what do you get for the 25 Grand
he's like I'll make you a report they'll
make you a report an eight page report
telling you we think that you should set
up a trust in Bermuda
and that is going to cost you
um 30k
the 25k that you paid us you can put
that towards the trust in Bermuda
um but basically he's just taking a cut
he's just taking a Reese he's just
taking a referral fee from the lawyer
you know it only costs 5K to do the
trust so basically and then if he gives
you the report and you don't like it
um he keeps the 25k so this is this is
the business model that um the Think and
Grow Rich guy does and Dave Ramsey I've
come to realize so what they did is I I
know somebody who reached out to uh who
got into Think and Grow Rich Robert
kiyosaki's like you know book Plus
uh Poor Dad Rich Dad is the Robert
Kawasaki guy or whatever his name Robert
something they can go rich as Napoleon
Hill yeah yeah sorry that's what I meant
Rich that poor dad oh did I say they say
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah so uh he reaches out to the Rich
Dad Poor Dad guy uh who I think is that
Kiyosaki guy and he's uh uh basically
that like he's got a philosophy he's
like look this is the way to get rich
and it makes sense and you're like cool
I want to do it he's like awesome reach
out to one of our uh you know reach out
to our headquarters and we'll do a call
and we'll get to know you and we'll tell
you what we think you should do and it's
just a layer reselling tax strategy and
so what he did was he paid 20K to these
guys to get a connection to a tech
strategy lawyer attack strategist and
lawyer
who then
did uh you know saves him a bunch of
money I actually saved him like 80k or
something like that so he's like oh yeah
there's a great deal I put in 20 got 80.
then he introduced me to the tax guy and
the tax guy is like cool yeah for all
this it'll be 6K and I was like oh but
like I saw my brother I was like you
know you you paid 20 I paid six what do
you mean and he was like well
yeah like that I was like where did the
other you know what were the all the
other money goes like Oh that goes to
like their Central agency like that
filters the deal so they don't just take
a cut it's not like we get a 10 referral
fee they mark up the whole service by 3x
and keep 66 of the 3x markup in order to
do this and then Dave Ramsey does the
same thing so I was like you see Dave
Ramsey right like you know America's you
know favorite uncle or whatever and he's
doing this call-in show he does all this
stuff and I was like how much and we had
done this feature on him on the Pod that
blew my mind Sam you knew a little bit
about this but he has like a huge campus
of like his office is like uh it's in
Tennessee he's got like you know
multiple buildings hundreds of people on
staff and I was like dude how big is
this guy's podcast that he could pay for
that that sounds a little outrageous
like what's going on here and it's
basically the podcast the books all of
that is just lead gen for people to come
to him and if you go to his website
it'll say what do you what do you need
you want Insurance you want a mortgage
you want to learn how to save money you
want tax help
talk to people with the Ramsay shield
and basically what he does is he goes
and finds local people in your Market
they have to pay to apply so they pay
some number some amount of money and uh
like you know a couple thousand dollars
to get certified and when they're
certified so he makes money off them but
then he for them it's a no-brainer
because they're going to get leads from
his giant top of funnel like his website
if you go to like uh whatever
the traffic you know analysis
um on similar web it says it gets 10
million visits a month on his website so
he's getting a huge amount of traffic
that he just funnels down to these
providers and he basically gets his cut
and they and these advisors all have the
shields like what does the shield means
like our team has vetted them as they
invented what you don't know if these
guys are you know what are you actually
doing out here and I'm pretty sure this
entire business is making like 300
million a year
um and this is off or more a combination
of basically his like the the Ramsay
trusted advisors and it's basically like
they follow the Ramsay rules
um and it's like what are the Ramsey
rules it's like oh you know there's
parts of his philosophy that they follow
and um
and so they can they can either pay for
the leads or they pay for the
certification and just off this lead gen
he's just generating just like tons and
tons of cash and then on top of that
he's got his like his university and
then he's got his media ad stuff so the
combination of all those is sort of like
uh a 300 million plus a year Empire
which is pretty insane it is doing
exactly what you described Jack it's a
it's a layer that I call it a router
business it's going to route you to the
service you want yeah and you know I'm
the router because I'm the trusted
source and if I do actually do a good
job of curating or hand selecting and
people get a good outcome from it then
this can be a sustainable business and
so yeah I think you're absolutely right
on that and what's the other one yeah
what says rtfm what does that mean oh um
rtfm I just meant like read the
manual so basically I was talking
someone
um have someone helping me with like
mid-journey and all this stuff just came
out right and then I was just trying to
figure out like I kind of just delegated
to him like all right we let's just see
if mid-journey can help us so as I said
I'm building this like physical place
and I'm like just see if it can make us
some mock-ups so take this image of a
cabin and this image of the piece of
land and just see if mid Journey can
blend them together and we even hire
people of upwork to uh and fourth Fiverr
like mid-journey experts to help us and
the results sucked and then they was not
doing what I asked and then he had said
he'd been playing around with for a
while and then I was at some point I was
like I it I should this is going to
be a valuable skill I should learn how
it works at least the first step I did
is I read the mid-journey
um guide book that they have
and it explains how to do it and then
within 15 minutes I saw like hey guys um
we can do what I'm asking you just have
to use this certain command do you even
did you even read the manual
about how this works I think most people
don't read demand like manuals are
boring right they read the manual
they're just trying to figure it out
themselves or look at YouTube and then I
was just like just read the menu it's
pretty simple and so I think
if you just do the basics that most
people don't read the manual
about how mid-journey works or chat GPT
or something there's so many people that
the AI is this merging Trend but they're
lazy I'm gonna read the 20 Page
manual and you can kind of just tell
them like oh you want to do that um I'll
just do it for you it maybe only takes
you five seconds but you can just charge
them a premium you know actually um my
wife she has a startup and she said
there's this guy
um he's going around he's doing
conference in a different country like
every few days about Ai and his teaching
Business Leaders like oh mid-journey
chat gbt that's how you use it this is
this ask my wife I'm like what's that
guy's actual credentials you know and
he's not he's not he's just a nobody but
he's saying that he's an AI expert
because everybody is it only just came
out recently and he's just running
workshops and charging Business Leaders
loads of money about how to implement
this in your business and so I think if
you just
you know if you just don't sleep and
just learn mid-journey chat TBT learn
all of these things only came out
recently you can be a thought leader and
write a book launch it launch on Amazon
a book how to use chat GPT in your
business and and launch it for each
vertical using chat gbt for lawyers and
accounting and whatever
um you guys are in the group I don't
know if you saw um Sean is more active
say I'm not but
people were talking about this business
case text just got acquired by Lexus
Nexus for 750 million dollars and
actually in the investor report it's
kind of embarrassing but in the investor
report the um Lexus Nexus said the
reason we pay 700 million dollars for
this business is because they came up
with eight prompts football open AI
about how to make it give good responses
um to law questions so they're kind of
openly saying this business is just a
layer on top of open AI they just came
up with eight prompt texts and so we're
buying them for 700 million tell me more
about this company I mean I'm not an
expert but someone in the group who is
in the industry said LexisNexis is
competitor has just come out with some
AI thing and so Lexus Nexus which is
like multi-billion dollar company was
like oh like we need to get up to
speed and we need to get up speed fast
and so they just paid this load of Chris
or what people are saying is ludicrous
son
um because it needed to get up to speed
but literally in the investor report
they said the reason we are buying this
business is because they have eight
proprietary prompts and then anyone
who's used TPT or anything knows that's
like not very much intellectual property
or whatever you're buying you know I
think case takes has been around for
like 10 years though so whatever they
were doing before uh you know they were
they were around uh so like I think they
have like on their website their
analysis ten thousand law firms use them
so you know it's not literally just uh
eight props but but I get I get your
point and definitely they got the uh the
AI premium on the exit here because uh
yeah it became strategic immediately
strategic and Urgent for for Lexus and
I'm totally with you about the the you
know you could become an expert in
mid-journey and chat GPT and like
nine days
nine days of like trying to do and
then basically figuring out how that
applies to certain vertical or job is uh
is definitely like a a thing that that
can exist and should exist I had the
same thing I was trying to use it in my
business my econ business and I was like
how do I do this and I just reached out
to the guy at Runway and I was like hey
I'm trying to take an image and make a
very similar image
and I was like it's not I don't like I
can't do text to image because I can't
describe this image I have an image I
want another one like it and I want
actually 50 variations of it can you do
that he's like oh yeah we have image
damage just go over here and I was like
oh thank you like this would have I
didn't know even which tool to use I
would have known what it's called I
would have known how to do it and then
oh I did it but there's one problem he's
like oh just change this setting uh blah
blah and then it just fixed it I was
like wow that's uh
that's amazing it saves me so much time
and you you really do have to play with
these things and most people don't have
the time or the patience to go play with
these things to figure out how they
actually work
as a business leader you pay your lawyer
a thousand a thousand five hundred
dollars an hour to give you tax advice
right why would someone not pay that for
a mid-journ person if they can answer
their question in an hour
um for a worldly a thought leader
Mark Cuban has this great blog I don't
think he updates anymore but he was
writing it for maybe a couple decades
now it's really old and I used to go
back and read his old post and a lot of
people don't know this but he actually
got his first like two or three million
dollars of wealth when he was 31 because
he started this thing called micro
Solutions it was basically I forget how
he described it but it was basically
like a like a I.T agency so like if a
big-ish or even a small company was like
implementing Oracle or something like
that he would help install it on
everyone's computer and then teach
people how to use it and he uh he goes
the reason my company was successful was
it because I necessarily was an expert
on this stuff but he goes I was the only
one and he used their same acronym he
was I was the only one who read the
manual he goes I would stay up
late at night and I would read the
manual and I would just learn
how does this HP computer work and the
next day I could go and like talk to a
business owner and explain how it works
and say yeah we can install that thing
or this thing or that thing and then I
would go and read the manual on those
other things and that's all I did and it
was hard work and I stayed up all night
reading these things but that's how I
became uh an expert in the stuff is I
just read the manual which no one does
and it's pretty funny because he used
the exact I think he has a blog post
actually that has the exact same acronym
that you have here's what he said
exactly it's a blog post called how to
win at the sport of business he goes
every night I would take home a
different software manual and I would
read it of course the reading was
captivating I'm reading Peachtree
Accounting word star Harvard Graphics
you know Lotus Apex at the every night I
would read some after getting home no
matter how late it was it turns out not
a lot of people ever bother to rtfm read
the freaking manual and so it turned so
so people really started thinking that I
knew my stuff and that's all I was doing
yeah that's hilarious and he like talks
and he talks about that in a ton of
different blog posts where he talks
about read the read the freaking manual
it's it's quite good uh any and he
attributes that to like a lot of his
early success you have a few others that
I gotta ask you about okay so you wrote
on this little cheat sheet you wrote uh
you know non-obvious barriers to entry
for business and then he said hacking
the iPhone to record screen uh what are
you talking about here non-obvious
barriers barriers to entry for business
sure and I mean as I said you don't have
to be the first mover to Market but um
to be successful in business but when an
entirely new product comes out there are
opportunities to
the product that's why I was able to
hack LinkedIn ads that at the hack we've
talked about for because LinkedIn just
launched it so it was not properly bug
checked and all that stuff you know now
the idea I was saying or it's not
necessarily a business idea about where
you could discover opportunities for me
and to give an example is that um you
might have a wedge or like a business
you might have a you might have a hack
this it's not a business but maybe it
can go somewhere from that initial kind
of hat you know so to give an example
with fungal
um back in like 2010
um the business I had before we were
making educational videos like how to
use Adobe Photoshop and stuff like this
so like videos about desktop like
Computer Applications and
um fairly around that time I think a
year before the iPhone app store had
launched and I was reading this Gartner
report like all right iPhone apps are
gonna blow up and then I was going
feeling like wait so we're doing this
for desktop and
um apps on your computer why could we
not do the same on your iPhone now that
nowadays it's very easy to record your
screen on the iPhone right like you just
pull down and tap this called screen at
the time you could not record the iPhone
screen
now I read a little bit online and I
kind of felt like hey I think I've
looked up these different pieces of
Hardware it's like
um a camcorder mixed with like this
cable you plug in with the iPhone but
you have to jailbreak the iPhone etc etc
I was like I reckon or I just have a
hunch that if we put these together I
might be able to figure out how to
record the iPhone screen
now my co-founder he was like do this
waste of time like you've got 48
hours to try this out otherwise we need
to move on all right
now not that many people know this but
actually the Apple Store lets you buy a
product and you can return it within 14
days even if you used it the MacBook an
iPhone an iPad you can return it used so
we had an intern it was his first day
there and I basically said our company
we have about a thousand dollars in the
bank account and I told him like the
take this credit bank credit card and I
told him to spend our entire budget at
the Apple Store I want you to buy the
latest iPhone and latest iPad and your
first task as the intern is jailbreak
this and we have 48 hours to figure out
if we can record the screen from this
because my co-founder thinks it's a
waste of time I think it's not and and
we and then we're going to return it off
within 14 days so we have a Time Time
buffer because we don't have a thousand
dollars to just throw around so we're
going to play around with this iPhone
Max 14 days then we're going to send it
back
we managed to record this we managed to
record the screen it was a free it was
taking like a cam called a cable you had
to jailbreak the iPhone
etc etc but we managed to get this
unique thing where we could record the
screen of the iPhone
at that time we didn't have anything
useful to do with it it's like okay
great we can record the screen in the
iPhone what can we do this but later on
when we built the video ad Network
um when we came up with the idea about
the video ad Network that vungo is today
um obviously if you're gonna run a video
ad an app needs to have an advertisement
to run right
and we were the only
um because we had just started with this
we actually just had an in-house
um Production Studio
that's how we initially made money but
charging 500 to make a video for your
app but 500 that kind of sucks but what
we do is we parlayed that idea and at
some point we made the best videos of
anyone like app loving or whoever they
couldn't make a video so what they'd
have to do is you'd have to spend
thousands of dollars hiring creative Ad
Agency who probably used a camera to
record the iPhone screen or you had to
do loads of work as the app developer
and send them all your image assets we
could literally record the screen with
the iPhone that others could not and so
what we said is like hey guys we're no
longer you can't buy a video from us
anymore like people loved our videos the
best quality videos but we're like even
if you offer us two thousand dollars we
don't make videos anymore
but if you spend more than twenty five
thousand dollars on our advertising
Network we'll make you the video for
free
and our videos are the best so they're
gonna convert amazingly as well but you
can you can use the video on your
website and stuff but you cannot use
this video on app loving or any other
network it's proprietary to us so that
was a hack that worked for fungal and
what I would say
obviously you have to have a credit card
that had this limit and check that Apple
actually allows this but what I would do
is if I am 20 years old and I have a
credit card because America gives
everyone credit cards I would go to the
Apple Store the first day the Apple
Vision Pro comes out and I would try and
hack it and jailbreak it and play around
with it look up on my head so I'll write
it and I would try and find hacks like
how to record the screen of the Apple
Vision Pro that's not going to be a
feature at day one no one needs to do
that if you can hack it and do that you
have something proprietary you could
launch your business off the back of
that and I would return it within 14
days and maybe go to another Apple store
and buy it and get my friends fire or
something but that um is one opportunity
of like you know it's a hack it's not a
business but that unique hack that no
one else has can lead you to have a
barrier to entry to be successful and
build a billion dollar business in a
tangential industry from there I love
that I love that you you also have a
couple on here you said why I Believe In
The Law of Attraction and practice
applications this is interesting to me
because I think
there's like people who believe in the
Law of Attraction and they also you know
believe in horoscopes and crystals and
other stuff too probably and then
there's people who are you know
hyperological rational Problem Solver
types that typically don't believe in
something like the law of attraction I
would have pegged you as more of the
Practical uh logical Problem Solver type
but you're saying you believe in this so
tell me why you believe in this and what
do you mean by practical applications
yeah people that are really rational
um like my brother-in-law is a bit hard
to talk about this topic because they're
so rational I'm pretty rational but I'm
also open-minded stuff now Law of
Attraction the interpretation of many
people with the crystals take and I kind
of it was kind of funny because I went
to somebody that did this alternative
kind of uh kind of like massage therapy
but like alternative and then she was
doing it at her house
um but then on the bookshelf was like a
book like how to manifest well to be
like a billionaire or something but then
I'm like um well you're in this like
really crappy studio so how's that going
for you you know like on the extreme
alternative side that you're talking
about Sean like doing horoscopes or
whatever I'm somewhere in the middle
where I'm like
Law of Attraction so popularized by the
book called The Secret
um if you just do it at the basic level
it's just like oh just like think about
what you want and it will manifest and
appear to you but actually there's a
book that I like called practical Law of
Attraction and what it's kind of saying
to be honest it basically I didn't know
about this stuff when I was launching my
business but it kind of actually
reaffirmed the stuff that I was already
doing in my life to be honest which is
like
clearly the clearly feeling and defining
what you want and then taking steps to
get there now why I think there's a
practical application and why I do
believe in it I don't believe that you
just think of it and then nothing
happens I think
now to give up um Let me give let me
just give an example story that
reaffirms this I was I was living with
my roommate and at this time my business
was going pretty good but he was trying
to launch a business off the ground and
he was 35 and he was trying to fundraise
raise a c round and he could not raise
any money at all
and his mindset was just stuck about
feeling sorry for himself like he was
just like oh I read on TechCrunch about
18 year olds getting into y combinator
but nobody respects me like I have way
more experience than him but investors
they must just they don't value me they
they blah blah he's feeling sorry for
himself he's having negative energy I
mean a prime example of it was like one
day uh he called me and like uh really
like anxious and he's like oh my God
Jack like um a letter from the IRS
arrived for you and I'm like uh dude I'm
sure it's not that big of a deal but
he's like dude what the that he's
freaking out right and uh lo and behold
it actually was a refund check they were
giving me a which one but he had this
negative mindset and I feel
that obviously people study by Body
Language and all this stuff but
I feel that law of attraction works
because there is so many micro signals
and Body Language we're projecting to
people all around us that we're not in
control of and don't even know and so I
feel for me
I and my co-founder we were convinced
we're going to raise funding and we're
the
and I think that investors and stuff can
tell you know you can tell if someone's
bluffing so he's going into this meeting
and he's got 100 projections and he's
feeling sorry for himself he's already
going in with the idea that these people
um are not going to invest in me and so
they are just sensing that this guy's a
loser right
um versus me
I'm just like we're going to raise
funding and so when I say something like
an investor one time asked us like how's
your fundraising going we had no
investors but we told him like oh it's
going amazing we're just we've got a
bunch of top tier people interested
we're just deciding who's going to be
the best fit for our business and the
guy kind of freaked out and it actually
gave us a term sheet because I think he
could tell that we believed it we were
not lying because we actually believed
it now what was amazing with my friend
is at just at some point
I just noticed him adopt a mind set
shift just one day basically and at some
point he basically just said like all
right look what I've been doing thus far
it hasn't worked and and he also was
saying that he looked at me a bit as a
bit inspiration because Jack just it
doesn't not worry about this stuff you
know and he's like I realize that
I haven't going been going all in
because I'm scared that if I don't raise
funding I'm gonna look like a failure to
my network as if I try and do a business
again then they'll think like oh well he
failed the last one I'm not going to do
it again but he's like he's like from
this day forward I'm adopting a mindset
that if I do not raise funding for this
business I'm never going to try and
raise funding for a business ever again
this is my one shot and I'm gonna go all
in and he looked up all his connections
on LinkedIn and he was not embarrassed
about rejection or that he would look
stupid to them in future he's like I'm
going to ask every single person in my
network for investor intros literally
within a month or so he raised amazing
seed round business now has raised over
25 million dollars because he just went
all in and I think that people could
tell that he had the conviction you know
he's telling them now he's not feeling
sorry for himself like I can't wait
something he's like I'm going to raise
funding and this business is going to be
huge and just it was amazing to
see him adopt that mindset shift
um and so that is an example for me of
law of attraction is like yes you're
manifesting it and whatever but
you're actually believing it and you're
projecting it to others now think he's
adopted that new mindset right so if an
investor rejects him
in his original view that would have
reaffirmed his original view right like
oh all the investors hate me and I'm
never gonna raise funding because I just
got rejected if with this new mindset
actually it doesn't necessarily have to
change every single outcome in every
interaction you have but it also changes
how you view them if one investor
rejects him now you'll just be like oh
well I'm going to raise funding so I
guess this guy was just not fit I just
move on to the next one you wouldn't see
it as reaffirming that you suck you
would just be like oh this investor is
an idiot like I'm still gonna write
funding it doesn't distract you from the
path so that is what I was thinking
about when it comes to law of attraction
and I've we've been friends for a while
but I remember very distinctly and you
might need to fill in some of the
details right and I'll try to be vague
and you can decide what you want to
share but I remember distinctly I think
we were I think we were at my apartment
in Soma in Soma when you came over or we
could have been at my house in uh Glen
Park but I remember like distinctly
hanging out with you
and you had just fungal hadn't sold yet
but you had sold some shares to live off
of because you were basically cat you
you didn't have a lot of money you sold
some shares and you you got maybe
hundreds of thousands of dollars but you
lived off that for like three years and
it was at the very end of that money
and you had you didn't even tell me I I
asked like how things are going um do
you have enough money to last until you
think your the company's gonna sell and
you're like
yeah I think it's gonna sell for a whole
lot of money for hundreds of millions of
dollars
um and I'll be fine when that happens
and I was like but how are you now and
for some reason I remember I saw your
Robinhood account or saw one of your
accounts and I don't know if you
remember this but I think there were
single digit thousand dollars left
because you had made like a really dumb
trade do you remember that and you were
like totally calm and I remember like
being around you and it was like
yeah you're you're one of my like three
best friends and I remember thinking
like oh like you're my family now like
you have inspired me because you
actually were living what you're talking
about now do you remember that you
remember when that happened yeah and I
mean in line with that basically yeah I
got a bit of money like as you said a
secondary right and I was living and
then the money was running out
doesn't last forever I think that I
um I I saw from the previous episode
people like talking about specific
numbers right so I think that when I
I think yeah I think that when I left
fungal
um and then tried doing and it
didn't work out Etc but I didn't have
any many savings and fungal I think I
got a hundred and twenty thousand dollar
salary we paid us after we raised
funding but prior to that we've never
taken any money and then just to help me
out because I was like Hey dude I don't
actually have any money
um
my co-founder fungal helped give me an
introduction to
um some people that bought a secondary
of of some of my stock now I think that
I I can't remember that I think it was
500 000 and I hadn't held the stock for
five years so it was not qualified this
thing called qsbs yet so I basically had
to pay a bunch you probably have to pay
half of that in tax being in California
right so I had like let's say 250k left
that's not a load of that's not a lot of
money in San Francisco to pay your rent
food you have no other income now I was
advising companies and stuff but they
don't give you they give you Equity
they're not giving you money and my
money was running out and Sam like you
said I didn't have much money left and
people were saying to me like hey dude
what are you gonna do if you like run
out of money uh and I was like oh I
guess I'll have to get a job but I'm not
really contemplating that right now I
don't have a timeline for when business
is going to exit but I kind of feel
something is telling me that is I'm
gonna be all right I'm not freaking out
about it even worst case scenario I'll
move back in my parents whatever but I
was not making a plan B what was the
dumb trade I was day trading like
options trading and all this and
kind of funny
um they're like 250k is not a lot of
money in San Francisco for food rent in
my day trading business
[Laughter]
hi and with hindsight is is very stupid
but like I was day trading and stuff to
try and
make some money when I looked back in
hindsight I actually was spending like a
few hours a day because I just got
interested in trading so learned options
trading and all this spending a few
hours a day I actually would have made
more money if I had just put it in the
Vanguard VTR if it's S P 500 as I wasted
all this time and yes lost a load of
money
um yeah so that was just a negative
trait of experimentation the way you
described it uh I've heard described
differently so Tony Robbins did this uh
this is a video on YouTube of him
talking about this where he says like
you know you've ever heard of the phrase
like a vicious cycle and a you know
vicious cycle is kind of like what you
described your friend was initially
doing which is he draws these three
circles he says first one's belief
second one's action third is results he
goes uh like what do you do when you
like let's say you're you're supposed to
do something but you don't really think
it's gonna work
um it doesn't matter what it is like you
know you're looking for the salt and uh
you know your girlfriend says it's in
the cabinet but you already looked there
you don't think it's there so you kind
of you go you don't really rummage
around too much because you don't
believe it's there right so basically
low belief typically creates we you know
low or weak action and lower weak action
almost always creates bad results and
then the the message the story We Tell
ourselves is see I knew it I knew it
wouldn't work and then it just
reinforces the low belief and that's the
Vicious Cycle that happens for people uh
you know it could be
uh uh I don't really believe that I'm
gonna stick to this diet and so
therefore I'm not really that hardcore
but I start to slip and then my results
say yeah you never stick to what you say
and then you reinforce a little belief
right it could be on and it could be
business it could be personal it could
be whatever
and then there's the exact opposite
which is The Virtuous cycle The Virtuous
cycle is massive belief this is gonna
work what happens when you believe
something's really gonna work you wake
up before the alarm clock you get out of
bed you start doing it immediately you
can't wait and you take Massive Action
what happens when you take Massive
Action for a while you start to get good
results or massive results when you get
massive results it reinforces the belief
see I knew this was gonna work and
so that and there's basically that's the
difference between winners and losers is
which side of that cycle do you go down
and like the core thing is
there's some people who just wait for a
result to happen to to inform their
belief and what that basically means I'm
going to sort of wait hope to get lucky
and then I'll start to believe and I
think anybody who's in this kind of
entrepreneurial bucket the the prereq
for any result is the belief and uh and
you have to have that sort of massive
conviction or massive belief in yourself
and in what you're doing and that part
is that that's the Law of Attraction
part that's the part where it's faith it
hasn't happened yet you believe it will
happen and because you believe it will
happen you're right it's not like law of
uh not like the secret where they're
just like close your eyes and you say
I'm not you know there are no weeds in
the background there are no weeds in the
backyard you look oh there's still weeds
in the backyard well you didn't take any
action you didn't go and get rid of the
weeds is is you know the action is a is
a requirement to actually do this you
also mentioned one other thing on that
which said you have to feel it
versus just say it yeah is there a
difference there because I when I talk
to people who who kind of really believe
in this uh they over emphasize this
feeling feeling it part versus just
saying it or uh or trying to believe it
in your head it's my wife is totally not
into this at all and maybe it just
doesn't work for her but she's like dude
I can't just feel that I'm gonna can't
just feel all it's gonna work it doesn't
work for her but for me maybe I'm just
delusional or I just have conviction in
something but I just sometimes just feel
it's gonna work and I guess um one bit
that is related to this a bit is like
perhaps adopting different mindset
personas so I saw this interview with
Beyonce and they were asking her about
like she has
um her thing like Sasha Fierce right her
nickname and they're like when does when
do you become such a fierce and when you
just Beyonce the same as a joke but
she's like I literally become Sasha
Fierce before I'm going to go on the
stage because when I'm Beyonce I'm
nervous I think people are going to hate
me or whatever and I just adopt this
alternative Persona that I Am Sasha
Fierce and I am going to kill this
performance people are going to love it
it's amazing because they're adopting
she's adopting some Persona and she's
really feeling it I I don't necessarily
adopt this other persona but that is the
feeling that I think uh would be insane
yeah I do the same thing and I also
think that um who do you become I have
this Persona that I created Angry Patel
like what are you who are you going to
become and uh yeah again this is another
one that came out of Tony Robbins he he
goes um he goes we all have we all have
a version of our personality like you
know raise your hand if you've ever been
um super kind to others yeah yeah
everybody raise your hand raise your
hand if you ever made selfish choices
and been a selfish everybody
raises their hands we all have all these
features of our personalities like the
question is who's driving the car right
now and he's like you know people think
that they come to this this weekend
workshop and I'm gonna oh Tony drop is
he changed your life In fact when you go
home people sort of mock you like oh so
what happened you're a whole new guy now
and he's like you know obviously you
don't
um you know you don't
become a whole new person after 35 years
in one weekend but he's like you know
one thing we will do because he's like
I'm gonna take the most badass version
of you and that's who gets to drive this
weekend and if you if it's only for this
weekend and you decide after this
weekend I don't want that person to be
the one who's making decisions from now
on all right fine fair play but for
these next two days that's who's in
charge we all have a version of
ourselves that is the more badass
version of ourselves the one that that
does believe it's gonna happen the one
that one that is decisive versus
indecisive all these traits he's like
what do you call he's like what do you
call when you um I forgot what he says
like he's like we're gonna make that
that uh he's like we're gonna make that
personality our he's like what do
you what do you do what do you train a
dog you give it a name and you train it
to come when you call it and he's like
so you're gonna give it a name you're
going to figure out how you're going to
be able to adopt that state when you
want to be in that state he's like that
takes practice reps and we're gonna get
a bunch of reps at it this weekend and
you sort of you have to figure out all
right what is the version of me that
does have
those traits that does walk that way
that does make those decisions and then
can you call it on command or are you
only going to do it when you feel good
are you only going to do it when the
weather's nice like no no you want to be
able to have that on demand when you
want it he says the same thing like I
think his real name is not Tony Robbins
either it's like his original name was
like Anthony he's got some other last
name he's like people see me now and
they're seeing me on stage and all this
stuff they think oh man Tony you're
you're amazing you you know you're just
special he's like no I was Anthony blah
blah I was broke I was fat I was all
these things he's like I created this
Tony Robbins I created him
and I was just like I like that part of
the the thing that he was talking about
because it's I think more empowering if
you feel like oh you just are the way
you are and that's it you're a fixed
quantity and it was you know it's based
on your genetics it's based on your
childhood things you didn't have control
of versus this idea that oh I actually
have multiple versions of my personality
there's some that I would want to be in
charge more often than others
um and I can craft that I can create
that version of me that I want that's a
different mindset some people don't
believe it some people are like really
married to their kind of like their
upbringing and their past traumas and
their their DNA that's not uh that's not
how I look at the world at least dude
this is get me this is getting me am I
feel good I feel like I need to go I
need to go create my version of Sasha
Fierce um
Jack I um
you inspire me I'm happy I feel thankful
we're friends I feel thankful that you
came here you're a very inspiring person
I just feel I feel you you're you do a
it's like you're you're almost not
inspiring because you're not this like
crazy intimidating person but or I guess
you're the right type of inspiring
because you're not this like crazy
intimidating person but you have and you
have a very you're very mild manner I'll
be with you and um other friends and I'd
be like uh Jack like you I already know
you know all about this topic that
they're talking about you but you're
just sitting here asking questions why
aren't you like pumping your chests more
or like you are dressed like this bum
right now at this thing all these people
think that you're just like one of my
loser friends but you're like you know
successful not in terms of just
Financial finances but you've got like
this you're my spiritual friend dude can
you uh yeah help me out here a little
bit well I'll be like you're like
successful in like all attributes like I
know you're like really insightful I
know that you're successful
traditionally you've got all these like
amazing things but you're you don't even
like you want me to brag about you
that's like I feel like I've got to like
sometimes like put you in a pedestal and
and but that's one of the things I love
about you is like you're just very very
Meek is a bad word because that almost
sounds insulting but you're very humble
uh and you're very mild-mannered and
that's one of the reasons why I love
when you come on here and you like
explain some of these stories because
you never ever brag about yourself and I
like hearing you do that every once in a
while check yeah well thanks for having
me on again I mean uh pick you up on I
mean what is very important for me just
to I guess just from my childhood and
stuff but I've always tried to be humble
and I'm not judging any it doesn't
matter I will have an in-depth
conversation with like to give you an
example I'm here in Portugal right and
there's a guy I pay a guy to come and
pick up at my recycling
out at my cardboard he's taking the
cardboard to the trash so the trash man
I'll have an in-depth conversation with
him about how his life is going and
stuff like that and I think it is good
to remember that you can be successful
and still be
humble and not judge people about where
they're at now
um
Sam like your father-in-law lives with
like a celebrity and he said like the
celebrity just it lives in the
same apartment complex and treats
everyone like and ignores him he's
like and he and his they're both rich
and the thing to remember I think is
where people are in their life now is
not where they're going to be in 10
years and people if you treat them like
they're gonna remember like I when
I was 1920 we pitched a VC in London a
venture capitalist and we've been
speaking to the associates we had a few
meetings with them
and yes we have nothing an idea was
terrible but um the associate said like
hey the partners agreed to have a
meeting with you just like come by here
at like 6 p.m to come by the office
we're like okay this bit of weird times
come by but sure whatever and we had no
money like spent the money but my
business part especially was in a lot of
debt we spend the money got an
underground ticket went there Etc
in within 10 to 15 minutes at the
meeting getting started because the guy
was asking his questions is like
you guys don't have a business this is
just like and at like 6 15 it's
just like yo I've got to go to dinner so
this meeting's over
10 years 15 however many years it's been
more than 10 years later we still
remember that meeting
and that guy treated us like he's
still got a VC fund if he asked me for
deal flow I'm not gonna give it I'm not
going to pretend that never happened I'm
like dude I remember how you treated me
when I was
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better I call you
uh when I describe you to other friends
I said I think Jack is the most
interesting man in the world and I think
uh there's this great quotes like to be
interesting you need to be interested
and to me that's the perfect description
for you you're the most interesting in
the world because you're interested in
the most things at the most depth you
know in the highest variety and so I've
talked to you about you know five
different things and you've gone down a
rabbit hole in each one of them so it
turns out and uh because of that you
always have like a really interesting
point of view what's been the best find
like you're talking about this chocolate
rabbit hole you went down and you're
like you know you you may come out with
a different conclusion than the experts
or the people who've done this for a
long time what's an example where you
you kind of just get you came to a
different conclusions yourself
well it was actually I was listening
back to our last episode or maybe or one
of the previous episodes and it was what
we talked about there where it was like
I just looked me and my co-founder at
least just researched how ad networks
work for a week and then
um we were like all right we think this
is how it works and um Tomas who runs
Angel pad was like dude you're thinking
you come into totally different
conclusions in a week I was working at
Google for a decade and there's people
with Decades of experience in this but
we just fought from the principle of
just very Basics and so the first bit
similar with app loving is we were like
why are these ad networks charging
um based on how many times someone
watches a video we built a video ad
Network we were like apps they actually
just care about the end action so they
actually only care how many people
install their app or how much money
these users are going to spend in their
app they don't actually care how many
people watch the video so why is it that
the industry charges that way and so we
kind of made a bet and said we will
charge
it doesn't matter how many people watch
your video we'll just only charge you
based on how many people install it it
was a bet luckily it worked out
sometimes you have to kind of make a
gamble right like especially with an ad
Network we had no idea if the business
would work
because the unit economics are kind of
out of our hands right we don't know if
these ad network if it's going to work
you you always do weird stuff like this
that makes sense but I'm like no why
would you ever do that so
um like for example
you named Your Child So Jack has a
two-year-old now uh you named your child
baby yeah for the you told me you're
like I'm just gonna name her baby for
the first 12 months because I want to
get to know her
and I was like
dude like everything about your life is
weird can you just just do do something
normal for the kid and you're like no I
think I think this actually makes more
sense and then I got to know her and I
like and then you you should talk about
the naming ceremony but you did this
thing where you named her after a year
and you're like this name like it fit
her more and I had to get to know her a
little bit and I was like after a year I
was like that actually is makes so much
sense but it's so not normal but you're
always doing these weird things that
actually appear to be well you've done a
lot of stupid stuff but you've got a lot
of things that actually like are pretty
amazing but are not normal at all yeah
and and I that's one of my favorite
Parts about you you know what I mean
cool thanks and I mean also because I
listened to the pot a lot I noticed that
um you guys hadn't talked about Sam had
made a massive announcement on all his
social that now he's gonna be having a
baby
um and so notice you guys haven't talked
about that so I had some of the
different wackier things I've done with
my baby if you wanted to talk about them
a naming ceremony was one of them yeah
you know me and Sam just were just like
guys we're just like yeah um nice job
with the thing all right uh let's move
on
you know girls are like oh my God
congratulations I'm so excited for you
wow oh my God you look you're glowing
Sam you look amazing and I was just like
hey dude um good about the you know
you know all right let's talk about
business
the the your stuff's working
congratulations and we um well I wasn't
sure I wasn't sure like what I wanted to
put on the internet and I haven't
actually made my decision what uh Sam
posted a shirtless picture of himself to
celebrate the baby I was like oh wow
that is that is unbelievable combination
there like that's a what an upsell you
created in this photo
announcement with the shirt off flexing
in the middle of my stomach she was like
cropped out of the photo it's like oh
yeah by the way there's a baby over
there
hey that's the only reason why we did
the whole thing uh do you uh do you put
your do you put your kid's face on the I
don't think you have maybe on Facebook
Sean have you checked no I have but you
only do it on Facebook right where it's
just like friends well my wife does on
her own Instagram so you know that's
like but you know it's just her friends
so yeah I'm trying to decide what to do
I think I don't mind but I don't know
anyway I'm still like working through
that let's go through some of the things
you did on the parenting side Jack so
the naming thing Sam talked about it
yeah let's do this let's finish that one
so how did you come up with that idea do
you think it was a good idea and
eventually how did you actually end up
naming her besides baby
um so basically again coming like
basically I think one of my values maybe
is I don't like being told what to do
and relating to what we were just
talking about I also like to question
norms
so preparing to give birth
um
uh or maybe even yeah you're preparing
to give birth what I read online and the
Midwife Etc was saying is you have to
pick a baby's name before you leave the
hospital so we can put it on her birth
certificate and he'll stop and so and I
was like uh why
do you have to do that like that's quite
a short deadline they have to pick a
name before you leave the hospital after
you go through this traumatic experience
yeah I was like I don't really like
being told to do that like does you
really need a name or he or she like
just being born like do you really need
a name you don't really need and so
basically I researched and it varies
state by state but I found that
as long as both parents consent I this
was in Hawaii where I was as long as
both parents consent within the first 12
months you can change a baby's name
without having to go to court or
anything like that you just fill out a
form and as long as both parents consent
we just had like a no tree come to our
house you can change the name pretty
easily so I was like okay well
um I'll I mean the first conclusion was
I don't want to have to pick a name
before I leave in the hospital there's
too much rust for me and it's also
telling me what to do so
um my wife the last name was more
important to my wife because
um she's Korean and in their culture
they have like a book of last names and
whatever and so and we kind of made a
deal okay
the baby can have your last name but I
get to take a lead on the first name I
wouldn't pick it by myself but I get to
take a lead on what is it and so then I
was like okay well
we'll just have the first name as baby
and so um that is what we did at the
hospital like uh on the birth
certificate Etc so submitted it and then
I did get a call from the Department of
Health or whatever like a week later and
they're like okay we just want to
confirm
um I understand you've had a recent
birth just want to confirm the uh name
and I and I was like yes it is um
b-a-b-y and they're like okay so just to
cover Ace baby the name of your baby and
then it kind of surprised me because I
was like yeah that's correct and then
the guy was like okay that's cool I mean
actually I've worked here 10 years and
it has been one or two other people
who've done this before as well actually
and I was pretty surprised about that
but anyway and then
I also thought like um
in South East Asian culture like China
Korea maybe some other places they have
this kind of just for fun they have this
uh ritual when the baby is
um a year old or so they put it the baby
on the floor and on the other end of the
room they put down like a stethoscope a
law book stuff like this and they just
let the baby crawl and whatever it
picked it's like oh I picked a
stethoscope that means you're going to
be a doctor and then it's just for fun
like let's do this Indians do that too
but it's just three stethoscopes yeah
oh you're supposed to pick up all of
them
exactly yeah except like 50 years ago
they started adding like little motels
that you could pick you know they're
like oh nice
and for my bit then I was like all right
what if we actually did that but we just
have different names
so then she can pick her own name
because I also remembered that when I
was when when first joining High School
like the first day of school they were
like all right everyone go around the
room and say an interesting fact about
yourself and I remember I couldn't
really think about an interesting fact
about myself and I was like oh if I do
this then she's always gonna have an
interesting fact about herself right
like I picked my own name uh it's pretty
interesting so I was like that's pretty
cool and this like product Obsession
you've done this with babies so Jack's
actually The Best Gift Giver of all time
so what he does is uh like for my big my
big life events Hill um like one time
when we got married he sent me this
maybe like three really big boxes I bet
you there was like three or four
thousand dollars worth of products in
there and he'll send me like a variety
of products and then he sends you a list
of a paper that's like three pages long
and it's a detailed description that
says like this is blank the reason why
it's the best and you're like explains
it and it's like sometimes it's really
random for example he was like these are
the best bath towels because they have a
little bit of copper in them which
prevents molding or he even like my wife
uses lotion all the time he's like this
is the best lotion it's the best because
it uses this vitamin or whatever and it
was like crazy or it was even like these
are the best
um gummy bears because they're low in
sugar but they still taste sweet but
they only use Stevia and you did it with
like maybe 50 items and then when I told
you we were pregnant you sent me this
box but it was all baby stuff and you're
like this baby formula it's meant for
babies that are three months old but I
actually think it's best for newborns
because it's the same thing as the
newborn one but like there's a small
very I forget exactly everything but
it's like this massive list and you're
doing now are you doing that now with
all the baby stuff where you're just
like literally analyzing every product
um yeah I test out quite a bit I mean
the reason I gave it to you as a gift is
because you and Sarah had told me like
oh you should create a business like uh
Jack's box of like your favorite stuff I
didn't actually want to do it in the
business because I don't think it would
make that much money and quite a bit of
effort but I wanted to do for you guys
because you kind of come up with the
idea
um I researched different products now
do publish your your research well um
not for baby products yet I was actually
thinking maybe to make like a b a baby
book or ebook
um just with different recommendations
you've seen um on my as my pinned tweet
on Twitter I have my favorite products
um just random products so I have
whatever favorite
I don't know what I've got on there but
I've got like 20 products I shared as my
favorites on Twitter and your underscore
Jack Smith that's your thing uh let's
talk about some of the other crazy
things you're doing so you have a guy uh
watching your baby on baby camera in
Pakistan or something like that what's
going on so you what are you doing with
this baby sleep monitor thing yeah I
mean um I kind of feel bad because you
know when when speaking to new parents
or if someone says like you're having a
baby like people say like oh prepare to
like never sleep again you're never
gonna be able to sleep I kind of don't
say anything but inside I'm like dude
I'm sleeping better now than I was
before having a baby
um and that's due to setting up various
things but
um one of those is that
I mean you have to have a house big
enough for this but basically we put
um my daughter a few doors down and so
um initially if she would wake up and
cry in the night we found that you know
she would wake up cry for like five
minutes then often go back to sleep
so she only really needed help if she's
crying like longer than that and I
actually got the idea from Jonathan
Swanson who's the founder of thumbtack
and he called it like digital night
nanny I called it like deep Sentinel for
babies
um I know Sam invested into Sentinel um
and basically what it's doing is having
a virtual assistant uh I have in India
and basically he just watches my baby
cam uh all night and he basically has
Specific Instructions like okay if the
baby wakes up and starts crying you
start a timer
and if she just cries for like three
minutes and goes back to sleep don't do
anything but if she cries for like more
than seven minutes then um call me and
wake me up and we have like you know I
have a special phone for that and we
have a backup phone in case that one
broke or something so um basically we
only get woken up if our daughter is
crying longer than seven minutes and
then so now I would say I only have to
tend to her she's two and three months
two years three months she now only
wakes up maybe once every two months we
have to go to her otherwise we don't
have to do anything so that was one
Jonathan Swanson came up with had been
really good for me what does that
assistant say uh that Indian person say
like when you're like yeah here's the
job
um I mean that's a pretty odd request
yeah
um well one of the guys actually it was
um I'd been working with this guy as a
virtual assistant and then he's he's
like oh my brother's in India he speaks
a little bit of English but not perfect
English he's looking for a job do you
have any tasks that I can give him and
then so I was just like all right let's
do this so I think for him pretty
awesome job because he can be multi-tart
he can be doing whatever else
um I mean the downside is that I don't
know how they're working this but he
actually doesn't take off a single day
in in the year he's working 365 days a
year now so I guess he's having like
Thanksgiving and Christmas and the baby
monitors on loudspeaker with his family
I don't know so he doesn't take any time
off yeah he's just not there Jack he he
has a look at the camera in months
he's like this Baby's two years old he's
gonna your baby's gonna have some
horrible separation anxiety I feel like
it's been crying for like 15 30 minutes
and like nothing ever happened your
baby's like his twitch stream so um what
about some of these other things so you
said uh I don't think that universities
will exist in 20 years and don't plan to
send my daughter to school let alone
College okay a bunch there say more
so why I'd read this book somebody on
Twitter had um recommended it and um
it's called like don't tell me I can't
and it's written by this guy a kid who's
like 14 and he is it's his Trend at the
moment it's trending now but he's he's
talking from his perspective that he was
doing this since three years old or
something how he was brought up that he
was not homeschooled like homeschooling
has been around a long time right he was
what they're calling unschooled
this is actually a trend at the moment
and he described how it worked for him
let's see how it worked for him is like
his family was super poor and also his
dad was an Army veteran like injured in
the Army and so was in a wheelchair and
stuff and so he was always kind of
helping to help out his dad and be
self-sufficient and so um and the local
school was like the worst in the country
or something and they didn't want to
send him there so initially they were
like all right we'll just try
homeschooling you and so he was
homeschooled for like six to 12 months
but it didn't go that that well and one
day his dad
um he said normally they were more
encouraging but for whatever reason one
day he just asked his dad like Hey Dad
how do people
um how do people get rich
and his parents were like really poor so
maybe also touched on an insecurity his
dad is just like oh why don't you just
figure it out yourself you know why
don't you just watch some videos of
Warren Buffett because I don't know
we're not rich and then he did that he
went and listened to loads of Warren
Buffett stuff
and it actually spiraled from there so
underschooling is the concept that
homeschooling is trying to replicate the
school curriculum right like all right
Math Science and you still have to do
the tests and all that unschooling is
there is no there is no curriculum the
kid just learns whatever they want to
learn and whatever is useful so he was
saying from around an age of like five
to seven years old he was repairing
their car and doing things like this and
he'd grown up in a poor family but he
actually started his own business
and by the time he was 13 he like
parlayed it like so initially he bought
a tiny piece of land
and got some animals on it and like sell
the produce in his local town and stuff
then he got he built he bought a super
run-down
um house that was falling apart and the
seller they'd built the house themselves
and so they didn't want to sell it just
for money but he's like hey look I'll
buy your Shack that's falling down and
I'm a kid and I'm gonna put on dedicate
all my time to repairing it so it's it's
restoring your legacy and so I really
liked that and they sold it in for cheap
he repaired it and then flipped the
house by the time he was 13 he had
something like hundreds of acres of land
he was managing and he said one time
when he was about 12 he went out with
some friends and they were complaining
about what they were learning at school
they're like oh we had to learn the
names of the planets in alphabetical
order when the hell are we gonna learn
that you would need to use that in life
you know they ask him they're like hey
Cole what what are you learning at the
moment
and it's like oh yeah well I've just
been looking into recently found it kind
of interesting how rich people generally
have like a pass through LLC and then a
C Corp and then they can deduct this
from their taxes on this and the other
kids are like what the is talking
about you know he got so not like crazy
rich but he got he was only 100 in his
dad he actually was like
loaning money to his parents he's like
they never asked me for money and I
never asked them for stuff but like in
tough times like I loaned money to my
parents I bought our car from them just
to help them out you know stuff like
that and then for me I was thinking back
in school like I learned piano in school
I had some piano lessons and in at some
point had to do like gray you you had to
do you know playing chords and I had an
exam and then it was just so
shitty you know it was not fun like I
don't want to learn how to play these
chords and music theory and stuff
passing exam and I'm like this sucks and
then I'm just looking now especially
nowadays kids learning piano they'll do
it by just seeing what's their favorite
song and they'll just learn to play the
song and that's just really fun and I
think that exams and stuff just ruin
the fun and curiosity of learning skills
and so for me my daughter I'm just like
how can I ensure that she's just having
fun for as long as possible and
um and like this kid said
that was unschooled he said like he
didn't learn traditional math but just
when but it seemed that he had a need to
learn a score a skill obviously he would
then learn it like he's doing his taxes
so he has to learn math to do his taxes
but it's not because they're like oh
learn the Pythagoras Theorem and you
have no idea when he's gonna use it he
identified himself I need to do my taxes
so I need to figure out how to do math
and I think that's just a philosophy
that I subscribe to a lot I mean is
wacky obviously but when you look like
Elon Musk he created his own school for
his kids Jeff Bezos created his own
school for his kids I think he only has
like seven kids I think that
um you don't have to be billionaire to
take this approach like billionaires
seem to be thinking the school system is
kind of up you don't have to be a
billionaire you could but also poor what
are you going to do then so fast forward
she's six or eight years old what are
you gonna do
or at the moment she goes to this thing
it's called is that another Trend it's
called Forest school it's actually
nothing to do with school basically they
just go to a forest a bunch of kids and
you're just playing all day like do you
have a fake mud kitchen and you are like
um picking oranges and turning to orange
juice and you see a sheep and I'm
I'm planning to just create my own thing
like that but going to a bigger age I'm
just like let's just bring a bunch of
kids anyone in a local school thing can
come around and also I feel like instead
of teaching them like how to write
and studying whatever I'm like wouldn't
it just be awesome like whatever topic
they they can pick the topic if I can
suggest some wouldn't it be awesome if I
just ping my buddy and be like hey Sam
could you just teach the class a lesson
on copywriting
or I kind of feel if they just ping
someone on Twitter if someone ping if
someone is if a 10 year old kid pinged
me like hey um I underscore myself and
I've decided I want to learn business
would you mind doing a lecture to my
class and
um we'll we'll have my parents will
bring us to you I would totally do it
um yeah so I'm kind of thinking stuff
like that so I love this
um my sister actually runs a school like
this called nature kids if they said
they're just outside all they just walk
around they go on Trails if they find
something they like learn about it and
if they want to go climb trees they
climb trees whatever and it's basically
has two two things one uh so she has a
traditional school and she has this
nature school and the Nature School the
kids are like by the end of the day the
traditional school kids are like dead
they have like no energy they're like
ready to go home and they kind of like
want to just watch YouTube or whatever
and the nature kid kids
even though they've been out walking
around all day outside they have like
way more energy which is like kind of
counter-intuitive that's the first thing
I've noticed um the second thing is uh
yeah like they know a bunch of things
that are interesting to them versus like
in school it's sort of like you know
you're forced to learn something that's
not that interesting to you and you sort
of begin to associate learning with
boredom learning with sort of like uh
you know being forced to do things
versus on the other side uh you know
it's self-driven it's great and exams
right yeah the pressure of that now the
the and I love the story you told about
that guy but my question would be I
think I think unschooling or sort of
self self-driven learning is awesome
when you're driven so what happens if
your kid is not trying to like
you know flip a house and learn through
learn about Pastor LLC he's like I guess
like the fear I would have and I think
most people would have is your kid
doesn't really have any interest they
kind of just want to you know sit around
and do nothing or uh you know they're
and so now you you're unschooled but
you're not really having this kind of
like awesome you know self-driven
curiosity do you like are you worried
about that or do you think like no I can
create that or this situation will will
mold a person to be more that way and
also on the other side what if she wants
to be a doctor or a lawyer where you
need uh you need to learn how to write
credentials yeah and you need
credentials
yeah I mean great questions I mean the
first side I definitely agree with you
Sean um and is one bit my wife has said
like you know some kids are not like you
jack wanting to I was trying to make
money when I was really little and stuff
and might not take that approach I think
just have to see how it goes as we go
along uh one other bit that was
interesting is um I visited a local
Montessori school and um so Montessori
studying it we're learning these
different things just my wife and I just
have interest
um but one bit they had which is awesome
is exactly as you said Sean School
finished and we went there at the end of
the day so whenever School finishes 4pm
or something actually there was a bunch
of kids still there and they have a farm
outside
and the head teacher was giving us a
tour just because my wife made friends
with them with her and she was walking
around speaking to the kids about what's
going on in the farm but she was not
telling them anything to do the kids
were just giving her an update so she's
like oh I see the rabbit cage is broken
like what's going on with that and the
kid was giving her like a detailed plan
like oh yeah we've seen this broken and
we've come up with a new Roofing method
that we're going to implement Etc the
kids run the farm and I was like that's
awesome what if you just have that but
just scrap the school part and the
school was also quite religious so like
what if you just scrap the religion part
of homage
um Sam about the bit if she wants to be
a doctor
um I mean
yeah I would guess one approach could
just like go yeah sit out of like or
take the total opposite approach and
just hire loads of tutors and be like
all right if that's the approach you
want to take then okay I guess we're
gonna have to get you up to speed faster
than other kids
um and I don't know how much you've
actually known when you're five in
school anyway so maybe just like all
right you've got if you want to do that
you're gonna have to be super smart and
skip a bunch of grades then uh we'll
help you do it but
hahaha uh
uh I don't I just I love hearing your
stories I mean we could we could do this
all day
um
I don't know what do you think Sean how
do you feel yeah I've had a few times
Jack where I just call Jack randomly and
I just ask him about something and uh
I think you are kind of more of a
one-of-one at least in my life of people
who are very uh
like I don't know independent minded is
kind of like the best way I would put it
uh like I think you choose to lead your
life how you want I think that's
inspiring I also think that you are
extremely
like Sam said sort of curious and uh
like I think you're a great competitor
when you need to compete in something
but you're not constantly trying to
compete with none asked for and that's a
very Silicon Valley trait people are
trying to compete in times that are what
are you competing on why are you trying
to you know show that you're the
smartest you're the richest you're the
one at most whatever
um it's an annoying trait and I think
it's great that you don't have that so
uh I don't know it's good good to talk
to you as always do you leave us with
either a book or product recommendation
one of Jack's finds that you think
people should check out that you're
passionate about you something you think
is awesome
um well the book that I mentioned I
guess the book that I talked about
unschooling is like don't tell me that I
can't
um and two uh I guess like uh
um spoiler alert like the kid it really
sucks because this kid was building
something amazing he actually drowned
and died uh right after we wrote the
book kind of sucks but it's a really
short book you probably should have
listened to me
yes a sick way to end it it's a good
time to end up
so what's the name of it don't tell me I
can't
um and then it's just still so book you
can read it in two three hours and
challenges a lot of assumptions you
might have about education and stuff and
so for me was like really inspiring
seeing this book I'm looking at your
products on here did you just say wait
beside did you just say she should alert
you should have listened to the line
yeah the library just tell them don't go
in he's like have you read my books I'm
going in
um you're an Jack I'm looking at
your Twitter list of products and you
have this buckwheat pillow I think I
bought one of these are these like hard
as a rock like aren't they just like
super super dense you can adjust how
much buckwheat is in it and then I also
have a pillowcase that divides into
three sections so you can why do people
love these so much they you need to get
used to it a little bit but actually it
cures my neck pain and I can't sleep on
another pillow and I think Sam you said
as well some of your friends even ship
the pillow to the hotel before they
arrive Nick Raiders Nick Gray is have
you heard of this Nick Gray our buddy
Nick Gray literally every time he goes
to a hotel he has his assistant send
this pillow to the hotel and then he
just leaves it there when he's done
every single time and sometimes if he's
going to stay at a place for more than I
think like four days he ships them a
mattress
I swear to God you could you if you
Google
I have a message from the hotel Google
Nick Gray pillow and he'll tell you the
story and I have been to like whenever
you if I'm in a city and he's visiting I
go to his hotel room and he always has
that pillow he gets it shipped there
every time how would you get rid of them
actress yeah well I don't but I don't
know what he does about the mattress but
if you Google it I think he has a blog
post on it but I but it's not just talk
I've like oh whenever he's staying
somewhere I'll go to his hotel just hang
out with him and uh the pillow's there
every time this is so funny wow so
basically it's the best for neck pain a
pillow normally is like you know it's a
rectangle and then but ideally you
actually want your head to have less
support than your net because otherwise
you puts your head at a weird angle you
know so with this you can pull the
backweet to one end and so it's giving a
lot more support to your neck whereas
your head is a bit lower and so it
allows you to kind of be laying
completely flat and so you're not kind
of crinking your neck and waking up with
like neck pain the next day I was
listening to this podcast of Derek
sivers on Tim Ferriss and Derek said
he's an interesting guy he was they're
like oh you do this one he has this one
business I think it's like web hosting
or something like that and
um
he was describing it and then Tim was
like why did you decide to do this he
goes
uh you know sometimes I'll pick a
project I'm paraphrasing her he's like
sometimes I'll pick a project because
I think about who's my customer and do I
wanna are those my kind of people and he
goes this is a business that lets you
host your own personal website and I
just realized that people who have their
own personal website for no reason like
just their own name.com those are my
kind of people and I was like oh that's
really great to figure out your filter
for like what's a simple heuristic where
like not everybody you like does this
but everybody who does this you kind of
like and um I think this like try every
product to try to find the best quality
of life levers
I think this might be one of those
things because everybody who I've met
that does this I like that person and uh
you're you do this Nick Gray does this
and uh it's kind of amazing
do you still have a sheet are you still
tracking everything I'm not really a
spreadsheet no I mean for example with
the baby box I sent you I just looked
around my house at like like I just kind
of anecdotally buy a bunch of stuff try
them all out and then send back ones I
don't like and just keep the best so I
wrote it down for you so I don't have a
fixed sheet as I said maybe I might turn
it into a baby book
um but haven't yet he had this closet at
one of his houses that I used to go to
and it was like again a walk-in closet
and it literally had I bet you it had
thirty thousand dollars worth of
supplements in there like it looked like
a it looked like a pharmacy it was like
um any bottle you could imagine and I
was like does any of this do anything he
was like nah not really you can't really
feel he goes except this one thing and
he had like a Ziploc bag and it had like
tar in it it looked like it was like I
was like is this like heroin what the
hell is this and he was like yeah it
works
yes it was like he's like this is like
Himalayan something and if you just take
a little dab of this this it gives you
so what was that it's called shillerjat
um have them consistently found it
repeatably amazing but yeah Himalayan uh
shimmy Jacks is like an extra from a
volcano or some crap
dude it was like I swear to God it
looked like a pharmacy it consistently
impresses anybody that you tell about it
that's what it does he had like scales
and it had like white powders on it I
mean it looks like a drug dealer and I
was like does any of us do anything I
don't know how much money you spend on
all that it was tens of thousands and
you're like this one thing is the only
thing that like is amazing it was like a
Ziploc bag of just this like tar
amazing all right jack we gotta wrap it
up this is fun uh thanks for coming on
we should do this again thanks so much
for having me love the podcast listen to
it and I don't listen to any other
podcast to be honest I just listened to
it in the car so thanks again so much
thank you
[Music]
foreign